la persona responsable de una enorme
fuga de secretos del gobierno de Estados
Unidos trabajó en una base militar Ese
es el titular de The Washington post que
tiene un informe exclusivo basado en una
entrevista con una fuente un adolescente
que dice que es el mejor amigo de quien
filtró la información que se identifica
como oji que significa original gangster
y en un video visto por the post se le
ve de pie en un campo de tiro
sosteniendo un rifle grande grita una
serie de insultos racistas y antisemitas
a la cámara luego dispara varias rondas
a un objetivo el hombre de unos 20 años
compartió documentos clasificados en
discord una plataforma en línea popular
entre los jugadores en un lugar solo por
invitación el periódico muestra los
contactos con sus miembros el grupo
contenía ciudadanos extranjeros
incluyendo de Rusia y Ucrania dijeron
los miembros un desafío a la advertencia
no form empresa en la parte superior de
tantos documentos que Oggy compartió los
documentos filtrados de revela en
movimientos de tropas en la guerra entre
Rusia y Ucrania evaluaciones sobre Irán
y Corea del Norte información sobre
China y muestran que Washington espió a
su Aliado Corea del Sur y el secretario
general de la ONU Antonio Gutiérrez se
trata de la peor filtración sobre
seguridad nacional en años en Estados
Unidos funcionarios de este país Todavía
están tratando de evaluar el alcance de
los daños están luchando para evitar que
la bomba diplomática erosione la
credibilidad de Washington el pentágono
ha puesto en marcha una revisión interna
del departamento de Justicia abierto en
investigación penal sobre cómo se obtuvo
la información filtrada